okay so wait wait I'm not in right I'm
creating that given young harmony I'm
feeling the in space that's right that's
what Aikido is so he's pushing I go
around and I turns out and fill the
space
it doesn't change when I would kick okay
so as he goes stay here look I'm not
blending with anything I didn't do
anything that is young instead it should
be like a two-man dance and I learned to
fill the spaces you see I'm filling that
space
not when I'm not when I want right go
this is what I want
he's taking me into it not here I'm just
waiting go no in blend what's the
difference this is a victim I'm blending
as much as he is so I am hunting as much
as he is as I'm coming in he should feel
my threat the entire time not this go
hunt hot
Shailja scoops
hey he's punting oh not very good time
[Music]
you could kind of resist it just the
same way as I've not yet and I'm not to
hit zero
see how I'm not pushing past your point
right I'm not pushing positive point
it's the same thing as Newton so I can
go let's see I'm contesting you're gonna
check me out I have to stay at zero
so again but YouTube back it's hard to
walk like it then so you go here and if
you bend it their waist do you feel the
pressure of my elbow - see I go here and
I go here I see low until I can't
that's when I drop forward go straight
slide straight okay so you can't that's
it that's it it's fine straight straight
that's it
[Music]
okay so he's hunting and I'm hunting but
we're both blending so now I'm gonna
pick up intensity and I'm going to see
if I can not cam into a victim mentality
okay victim mentality is he's going to
push back on me got it
and then what happens is so he gets more
in injury prone because I have
mechanical advantages okay so we're
gonna up to training and it's just a
psychological training a mindset
training I keep the hunting
he keeps the hunting and we see which
one loses the hunting mindset and time
starts to come into play okay so we're
off
[Music]
let's go